[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes bonsoir à tous merci
d'être avec nous sur TV 78 nous sommes
le jeudi 12 janvier voici le programme
les soldes d'hiver ont démarré hier elle
se poursuivront jusqu'au 7 février dans
un contexte d'inflation et de baisse du
pouvoir d'achat les clients n'étaient
pas au rendez-vous dans les boutiques de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines alors est-ce
que les soldes fonctionnent encore nous
poserons la question à Caroline Lee
gérante d'un magasin indépendant à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux cape sur plaisir
ce soir dans votre 7 8 quelles sont les
grands projets de l'année 2023 dans la
commune rénovation du quartier du
valibout réaménagement du centre-ville
fusion des polices municipales entre
plaisir et Les Clayes-sous-Bois nous
ferons le point avec Joséphine Coleman
berger la mère de la ville
connaissez-vous le quiz game il s'agit
un véritable plateau télé où les joueurs
répondent à des questions de culture
générale sur le cinéma le sport les
animaux il existe de nombreux thèmes
possibilités aussi de faire des blind
test énigma 78 amorpa et le premier à
ouvrir ce type de jeu dans les Yvelines
de journalistes de la rédaction ont pu
le tester nos découvrirons les colistes
dans cette émission et comme d'habitude
le jeudi Gabriel Gonthier vous donne ses
idées de sortie pour le week-end alors
Gabriel est-ce que vous pouvez nous
utiliser un petit peu ce que vous nous
avez préparé bonsoir Mathilde oui je
vous parlerai notamment d'un événement
insolite organisé par la ville de Poissy
mais lance sport et solidarité vous le
verrez pour soutenir les enfants
accueillis par les Restos du coeur on en
parlera dans la partie loisirs de cette
émission ce sera tout à l'heure avec
nous également en plateau Joséphine
Coleman berger bonsoir bonsoir alors
vous êtes la mère de plaisir et cette
année vous avez choisi de présenter vos
vœux au Plaisirois en vidéo pourquoi ce
choix je pense que c'est une année assez
complexe on a entendu parler de sobriété
d'économie donc il me en tant qu'élus
c'était plutôt bien de prendre cette
décision la tradition des vœux en
discours devant les plaisirsois elle se
perd un petit peu selon vous non elle se
perd pas parce que ses compensés par des
rencontres que nous faisons dans les
quartiers et puis nous faisons
énormément de réunions pour des
concertations de projets donc ce qui
fait que on est presque plus avec eux
que quand on présente les vœux parce que
finalement les vœux on peut pas
accueillir les 32 000 habitants alors
que quand on fait des réunions dans les
quartiers ben on rencontre beaucoup plus
de monde et donc tout à l'heure on
parlera des grands projets pour l'année
2023 à plaisir dans cette émission nous
retrouverons également Mélanie poquet
sur le terrain à l'Agence Locale de
l'énergie et du climat à Coignières plus
précisément la lettre organise des
ateliers de sobriété énergétique pour
les 50 chinois nous découvrirons en quoi
ça consiste avec elle dans un dans un
instant mais avant jetons un coup d'oeil
à la météo de demain
demain matin le ciel devrait être dégagé
du côté de Houdan et de Rambouillet dans
le nord-est du département attention aux
averses le vent lui sera encore présent
sur toutes les Yvelines avec des rafales
jusqu'à 65 km/h au niveau des
températures il fera 9 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et 8 degrés à Houdan
Versailles et Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi attendez-vous à des averses
entrecoupées d'éclaircisses sur
l'ensemble des Yvelines au niveau des
températures comptées 10 à 9 degrés en
moyenne et demain nous fêterons les
Saint-Hilaire alors je sais pas si vous
connaissez beaucoup d'hiver autour du
plateau
mais en tout cas ils ont leur fête le
point maintenant sur l'actualité dans
les Yvelines
et c'est avec vous Grégory canalet
bonsoir on commence par un fait divers
une conductrice de 20 ans a été placée
en garde à vue elle a été interpellé la
nuit dernière à Trappes pour tentative
domicile après un refus d'obtenté
d'obtempérer lors d'un contrôle de
police selon nos confrères de France
Info c'est son père qui avait signalé sa
fuite aux forces de l'ordre hier soir
elle lui a dérobé les clés de sa voiture
et à même failli le renverser un
équipage elle l'a retrouvé en très long
court et trap en train à inhaler du
protoxyde d'azote tout en conduisant et
dans sa chevauché la jeune femme a
percuté trois véhicules de police avant
d'être arrêté grâce à une barre équipée
de pointe pour crever ses pneus trois
pollutions étaient blessées le père de
l'individu est cinq fonctionnaires de
police ont porté plainte une sacrée
histoire on reste attrape Grégory pour
l'image du jour vous allez nous donner
la patate
de pommes de terre vente directe de
pommes de terre qui s'est déroulée toute
la journée sur le parking des Merisiers
un producteurs des Hauts de France
proposé aux habitants des environs des
sacs de 15 kg à 7,50 € soit 50 centimes
le kilo ce type de vente avait vu le
jour pendant le premier confinement du
covid 19 pour soutenir les producteurs
qui n'arrivaient pas à écouler leur
stock le camion continue de sillonner
l'Île-de-France et sera demain par
exemple à Vitry-sur-Seine dans le
Val-de-Marne les propos recueillis sur
place par Ludivine canard et Julien
Leroy attrape dès que je vois le camion
donc je me rapproche et ça fait pas mal
de fois que j'achète et ce qui m'attire
le plus c'est que le les pommes de terre
sont résistants c'est pas comme on
achète
dans les supermarchés nos pommes de
terre on devait les garder et donc on a
trouvé une alternative pour en faire
bénéficier tout le monde vu que toutes
les friteries étaient fermées et tout
donc on est vendait à prix coûtant voilà
et les gens à cette époque là les payer
un petit peu moins cher qu'aujourd'hui
mais bon aujourd'hui malheureusement le
gasoil
l'électricité et les charges voilà on a
été obligé d'augmenter un peu mais on
reste quand même attractif à 50 centimes
le kilo et pour connaître les prochaines
dates de distribution vous pouvez suivre
l'aventure sur Facebook sur pomme de
terre fontaine la personnalité
yvelinoise de l'année 2022 et dévoilé
Grégory
toutes les nouvelles qui établissent le
palmarès chaque année les lecteurs
votent parmi 30 candidats et livinois
plutôt même l'hibelinoise de l'année
2022 et Cécile Melo originaire de
Crespières elle explore le monde avec
des randonnées l'an passé à la fée de
l'exatrait alors de l'exatrac c'est du
trek dans l'Hexagone voilà ça ne
s'invente pas un terrible de 3000 km au
travers les montagnes françaises pendant
136 jours dans le classement aussi on
retrouve à la numéro à la place numéro 2
Julien de nerveau animateur de
l'émission l'antisèche sur marmite FM et
Didier ledemais que vous connaissez très
bien je crois Gabriel
chocolat effectivement il est boulanger
pâtissier dans la commune de Poissy et
il a remporté le titre l'année dernière
de meilleur pain au chocolat de France
il a même été reçu à l'Élysée pour cette
distinction du sport à présent Gregory
avec le retour sur le terrain du
Football Club de Versailles pour le
premier match de l'année 2023 ce sera
demain en déplacement face à Avranches
pour le compte de la 17e journée du
championnat de National et les hommes du
coach Chris non plus jouer depuis le 12
décembre et une victoire contre Paris 13
Atlético entre-temps il y a eu un stage
de préparation au Maroc les Yvelinois
sont pour le moment deuxième mot
classement à brancher 10e le coup
d'envoi est à 19h30 et c'est une
rencontre que vous pourrez suivre
gratuitement sur le site de la
Fédération Française de Football et pour
terminer Grégory vous avez trouvé une
manière originale d'aider les animaux
abandonnés c'est un géant japonais de
l'automobile on ne donnera pas la marque
ici mais je pense que vous avez compris
qui est à l'origine de l'initiative et
cette initiative s'appelle les essais
solidaires chaque minute passée en
voiture électrique lors d'un essai et
c'est un euro reversé à la SPA à la
Société protectrice des animaux la
concession de Magny-les-Hameaux
participent à l'opération du 13 au 21
janvier et l'argent récolté sera reversé
au refuge de plaisir justement pour
réserver votre essai rendez-vous sur le
lien qui s'affiche en bas de l'écran
initiative effectivement et si vous
aussi comme d'habitude vous voyez une
information qui vous a marqué près de
chez vous n'hésitez pas à nous le
partager en utilisant le hashtag 7 8
news
on en parlait en début d'émission
l'Agence Locale de l'énergie et du
climat organise plusieurs ateliers sur
la sobriété énergétique le premier a
lieu ce soir à Coignières et on retrouve
Mélanie poquet sur place alors Mélanie
est-ce que vous m'entendez bien
je vous entends très bien Mathilde et
vous êtes accompagné alors
je suis accompagnée de Laurence Mondon
l'atelier est sur le point de commencer
c'est le premier des 6 rendez-vous
proposé par l'alexky donc là en ce
moment vous êtes la responsable
communication et formation de la lettre
déjà pourquoi organiser ces ateliers
alors le l'objectif de ces ateliers
c'était de proposer quelque chose qui
permettait de rendre plus concret la
sobriété énergétique c'est un concept
qu'on entend quand on entend beaucoup
parler actuellement et donc ensuite
pouvoir informer et sensibiliser
justement à tout ce qui est sobriété en
général et sobriété énergétique en
particulier
informer de manière générale ou donner
même des conseils donner des idées au 56
mois un peu des deux
dans un premier temps c'est vrai qu'on
va essayer de réfléchir un petit peu
tout ça ce que ce qu'on peut faire au
quotidien et puis dans ne pas oublier de
rétablir le contexte dans lequel on est
et pour quelle raison c'est important de
pouvoir le faire oui depuis plusieurs
mois les 12 communes 50 ans en Yvelines
ont mis en place des choses mais donc un
particulier peut aussi
participer à cette sobriété oui tout à
fait chacun tout à chacun peut
participer que ce soit dans enfin c'est
souvent dans les gestes quotidiens qu'on
peut faire des choses l'important c'est
de se souvenir c'est sans perte de
confort et puis sans revenir non plus à
une époque souvent le pour certains la
solidarité c'est revenir quelques années
plus tard mais non on n'est pas question
de ça c'est vraiment continuer à vivre
c'est une sobriété qui est souhaitée
c'est pas une sobriété qui est imposée
et donc chacun peut choisir les actions
qu'il va mener dans sa propre dans son
propre quotidien pas de perte de confort
chacun ses gestes ce que vous en auriez
un qui serait peut-être primordial ou
que tout le monde peut faire et c'est
difficile pour pas de parler pour tout
le monde pour certains ça va être de
moins utiliser la voiture utiliser plus
le vélo parce que en fait ça permet
aussi d'être meilleur pour la santé donc
chacun va essayer de trouver les gestes
qui sont les plus faciles à faire pour
pour lui et puis à la maison ça peut
être des choses toutes simples mais
fermer les volets le soir pour garder la
chaleur mettre des rideaux pour éviter
l'effet parois froide voilà mettre des
boudins de porte ça peut être et bien
dégivrer son réfrigérateur régulièrement
le dépoussiérer aussi voilà en fait
va être acteur chacun va pouvoir
proposer ses éco gestes peut-être on
parlera voilà pour partager avec les
autres exactement
c'est un atelier de 2h est-ce qu'il va
derrière y avoir un suivi voir si les
équations fonctionné on parle de grands
défis aussi sobriété oui alors là
effectivement la première étape c'est
l'atelier et puis pour les motiver
la lettre propose effectivement un défi
donc avec un peu des informations
pendant deux mois des informations
hebdomadaires des petits challenges pour
se tester et puis également des
appareils de mesure qui seront prêtés
pour pouvoir mesurer aussi à la maison
quels sont les équipements qui
consomment le plus et pouvoir agir en
fonction de ce qu'on découvre au fur et
à mesure donc bilan dans deux mois si je
comprends bien merci Laurence mon alors
cinq autres rendez-vous sont proposés le
prochain c'est le mardi 17 janvier de
18h à 20h c'est à l'espace Philippe
nouraï des Clayes-sous-Bois et pour
s'inscrire rendez-vous sur le site de la
laïque Alec ski.org merci beaucoup
Mélanie poquet pour toutes ces
informations alors Joséphine comme
asperger la sobriété énergétique c'est
d'actualité comment ça se met en place
dans votre commune à plaisir c'est
impératif aujourd'hui ça se met en place
tout d'abord en collaboration aussi avec
les autres communes puisque nous avons
un plan de sobriété au niveau de 50
heures en Yvelines avec l'extinction des
lumières la nuit de 1h30 à 4h30 pourquoi
ces horaires c'est parce que on a
l'arrivée des bus et le redépard des bus
pour les gens qui travaillent donc on a
choisi volontairement cette horaire là
il y a aussi toutes les lumières au
niveau de l'éclairage public qui vont
être mis en l'aide alors c'est vrai que
c'est aussi une compétence de 50 ans
mais nous nous avions déjà commencé et
puis dans les bâtiments publics bien sûr
de la ville aujourd'hui et bien on a
toute une démarche des agents et de la
population justement pour éteindre les
lumières donc on a mis partout n'oubliez
pas d'éteindre les lumières le chauffage
bien évidemment nous l'avons baissé à 19
et nous avons un énergéticien qui a été
embauché sur la ville depuis de
nombreuses années qui nous permet de
faire des réhabilitations de nos
bâtiments justement pour prévenir toute
cette dépense énergétique oui finalement
ce sont des gestes de gestes simples
mais utiles au quotidien efficace on le
rappelle aussi vous êtes vice-présidente
déléguée au développement durable pour
l'agglomération de Saint-Quentin
exactement
dans l'actualité également les soldes
divers qui ont débuté hier pour ce coup
d'envoi il n'y avait pas de il n'y avait
pas foule dans les magasins 56 mois avec
nous pour en parler Caroline Lee bonsoir
bonsoir alors vous êtes gérant de deux
boutiques indépendantes à
Montigny-le-Bretonneux il est à Tiffany
elle et Créafil alors comment ça se
passe les soldes quand on est gérante
une boutique indépendante
c'est plus compliqué que que si on était
des une grande enseigne parce que on
doit tout étiqueter c'est pas toujours
évident et nous c'est des vrais soldes
c'est à dire c'est vraiment
le stock de l'année en cours
Conrad était a été et hiver à hiver on
n'a pas de plan de stockage on n'a pas
de
d'endroit où stocker la marchandise si
on la vend pas donc on est obligé de
vraiment brader nos articles pour
pouvoir par la suite commander notre
collection d'été et alors justement vous
les brader jusqu'à jusqu'à combien vos
articles 50 60 ça dépend des produits
puisque en réalité comme on est
indépendant on fait des tout petits prix
en vrai on travaille vraiment toute
l'année on travaille mieux hors sol que
pendant les soldes et ça fonctionne
encore cette année
c'est vrai que les sols ne veut plus
rien dire parce que on est promotion sur
promotion dans les autres boutiques même
si nous on ne l'est pas vraiment mais
serait tout au long de l'année on fait
des petits prix ou des fin de série pour
les dernières pièces ou qui restent ce
qui fait que pendant les soldes oui on
solde vraiment les plus grosses pièces
ou les bottes qui vont nous prendre
beaucoup de place et qui n'ont plus leur
place en rayon pour l'été
moins la période des soldes pour acheter
aujourd'hui on a plus tendance à avoir
un achat immédiat non alors chez nous
oui ils ont vraiment le coup de coeur
les gens c'est au coup de coeur peu
importe il faut qu'ils aiment le produit
et du mot qu'ils aiment ils vont acheter
Joséphine colmarger a plaisir vous avez
de nombreux centres commerciaux c'est
important cette période des soldes pour
la ville ça a l'air puisque hier j'y
étais je suis allée voir un petit peu la
température il y avait énormément de
monde alors c'est vrai que si on était
mercredi mais il y avait vraiment
beaucoup de monde dans les magasins
alors après pour le chiffre d'affaires
je n'en sais rien mais enfin au vu des
queues qu'il y avait dans dans les
magasins devant les caisses il y a
certaines grandes marques comme disait
madame qui effectivement fonctionne très
très bien après tous les magasins n'ont
pas je dirais c'est engouement là mais
je ferai mon ma petite enquête mais je
pense que les choses se sont pas trop
mal passées
et les boutiques un peu plus
indépendantes ça vous touche vous
Caroline non ça fait quand même 20 ans
qu'on est sur place donc on a vraiment
notre clientèle très fidèle que je
remercie d'ailleurs mais
non je pense que on est vraiment une
équipe très dynamique qui fait que les
gens reviennent facilement nous voir
depuis combien de temps est-ce que vous
êtes gérante de ces deux boutiques
depuis 2005 pour le prêt-à-porter
tiffanyel et on a récupéré la mercerie
il y a deux ans la personne elle partait
à la retraite je me disais bête de
laisser mourir une mercerie surtout
qu'il y en a plus
qu'on est pratiquement l'un des seuls et
rares de notre espèce donc ça fait de
nombreuses années est-ce que du coup ça
fait depuis assez longtemps que vous
voyez qu'il y a un manque un petit peu
d'engouement pour les soldes comme je
dis le manque d'engouement pour les sols
c'est fait c'est le fait que les gens
bénéficient de promotion tout au long de
l'année donc ils attendent plus
forcément les soldes pour acheter
et donc nous sommes allés poser la
question aux Yvelines noires pourquoi
pourquoi ils ne font plus les soldes les
propos recueillis par Ludivine canard et
Patrick Jacques de Dixmude et Régine
ralech c'est presque le mode normal
maintenant et puis des sols sur internet
il y en a tout le temps aussi en fait la
pression que ça donne c'est que le vrai
prix c'est les soldes et puis il reste
du temps c'est de l'arnaque pas grand
chose parce que il y a pas mal d'oeufs
sur Internet et du coup on fait plutôt
en cours d'année enfin tout le long de
l'année que plutôt attendre le moment
des sols pour le faire
donc les soldes il y a plus grand chose
maintenant je trouve ça sert à rien
c'est il y a trop de choses en jeu tout
va bien qu'apprendre à un prix correct
tout le temps c'est bon ça suffit on
n'est pas spécialement obligé d'attendre
la période des sols en elle-même puisque
il y en a dans le courant de l'année
exactement donc quand j'ai des besoins
je peux en profiter aussi dans le Coran
de l'année alors on l'entend dans ce
micro-trottoir les Yvelinois préfèrent
les ventes privées ou acheter sur
internet votre réaction par rapport à
tout ça Caroline dit c'est vrai que on
est très surchargé d'informations
d'envies sur Internet on est souvent sur
notre smartphone donc forcément on a
plus d'envies mais n'empêche que
les gens viennent quand même en magasin
j'ai cette impression que nous en tout
cas par rapport à la mercerie les gens
viennent et font des choses par
eux-mêmes et ont envie de préserver les
boutiques sur place donc il se déplace
on voit qu'il se déplace
vous comptez faire les soldes autour de
ce plateau
à petite barrée vous venez de nous
rejoindre vous allez faire votre
chronique sur les animaux dans peu de
temps mais est-ce que vous comptez faire
les soldes alors je compte bien faire
les soldes j'ai pas encore commencé hier
j'attends toujours la deuxième démarque
pas forcément parce que c'est vrai qu'il
y a des promotions assez régulièrement
donc je vois pas forcément là beaucoup
la différence et vous Joséphine j'arrive
à me laisser tenter c'est sûr si je me
promène un peu je trouve toujours
quelque chose qui m'intéresse c'est sûr
et alors au niveau de votre chiffre
d'affaires Caroline ni est-ce que vous
voyez une différence les sols ça marque
une différence pour nous pas
particulièrement les seuls parce que
c'est pas un moment phare de notre de
notre activité c'est vraiment lisser sur
toute l'année on a cette chance là que
c'est pas vraiment que les soldes ce qui
nous permet de travailler parce qu'en
vrai en période de sol on ne travaille
pas on ne fait que liquider notre stock
on récupère une trésorerie c'est pas ça
qui nous fait vivre si on est en solde
toute l'année on coule clairement
c'est pas possible merci beaucoup
Caroline ni d'avoir accepté notre
invitation les soldes se poursuivent
jusqu'au 7 février direction
Mantes-la-Jolie maintenant les
collégiens de Martin Luther King à Buc
ont visité mardi dernier le site de
restauration des statuts du château de
Versailles un chantier patrimonial rendu
possible grâce à la collaboration avec
le Conseil départemental des Yvelines
ils ont pu découvrir le métier de
conservateur et restaurateur d'art
Nicolas dandry a pu suivre cette visite
Vénus et Adonis à gauche et flore et
Zéphyr à droite deux groupes sculptés si
tu habituellement au-dessus des grilles
de l'Orangerie du château de Versailles
actuellement en restauration à
Mantes-la-Jolie ils ont reçu la visite
de 28 collégiens une visite guidée par
Anne-Laure Goron conservatrice et
restauratrice il y a énormément de
choses à dire en réalité parce que ce
sont des sont des œuvres qui déjà
elle-même sont intéressantes dans leur
conception la restauration elle-même est
extrêmement intéressante bien que la
dépose a été très complexe c'est
vraiment stimulant de transmettre tout
ça on fait on fait ça en fait on a quand
même un métier qui est un métier de
transmission la transmission du
patrimoine un élément qui est intéressé
les élèves du collège Martin Luther King
de Buc ils ont pu découvrir les secrets
du travail de restauration de ces
statuts j'ai appris la façon dont on
pouvait déplacer une statue pour la
rénover la façon aussi dont on pouvait
la rénover que ce soit remplacer un
membre ou juste la laver j'ai trouvé ça
hyper intéressant parce qu'on a
découvert plein de choses un univers
qu'on ne connaissait pas habituellement
et surtout l'envers enfin derrière une
statue ce qui se passe un peu c'est un
travail c'est long et il faut être très
rigoureux parce que il y a beaucoup de
pièces à coller de puzzle c'est un
énorme puzzle qui dure des années cette
visite s'inscrit dans un programme de
découverte des métiers d'art une
initiative menée par la professeure
principale de cette classe de 4e le
premier objectif c'est ouvrir la culture
de l'élève à tout ce qui est artistique
là la taille de la ou la restauration
des pierres mais il a aussi un objectif
d'ouvrir le champ des possibles des
métiers dans tout ce qui est parcours à
venir donc réflexion à l'orientation la
rénovation des statuts va se poursuivre
un chantier sur deux ans rendu possible
grâce au conseil départemental des
Yvelines pour les collégiens le prochain
rendez-vous est prévu lors des Journées
Européennes des Métiers d'Art du 27 mars
au 2 avril 2023
alors quelles sont les grands projets à
plaisir pour l'année 2023 il y a
plusieurs dossiers en cours notamment le
réaménagement du quartier du valibout en
écoquartier 64 millions d'euros sont
alloués à ce projet Joséphine Coleman
berger où est-ce que ça en est mais
écoutez on a déjà on a déjà commencé pas
mal de choses puisque il y a eu une
démolition importante du silo qui était
un énorme bâtiment qui enclavait le
quartier on a reconstruit une grande
cantine pour l'école Brossolette
Louise-Michel et puis Casanova ces trois
écoles qui vont fusionner exactement et
ça va devenir un groupe scolaire dédié
bien sûr aux enfants du quartier mais
pas uniquement parce qu'on souhaite
justement qui est une ouverture et une
mixité sociale on est actuellement en
réflexion justement sur la grande salle
associative que nous devons bientôt
mettre en construction il y a des
réflexions aujourd'hui sur la
reconstruction du centre commercial qui
va être entièrement démoli et réhabilité
depuis l'installation de la PMI et du
CCAS qui va venir aussi s'installer dans
le quartier donc tout ça c'est en cours
on est on fait pas mal de réunions de
concertation avec les habitants pour
justement les entendre les écouter et
puis bien sûr il y aura toute la
réhabilitation des parkings des espaces
verts puisque ça ça fait exactement
partie tout ça il y a eu 58 personnes
familles qui ont été déménagées d'un
bâtiment qui va être démoli ce qui n'est
pas énorme par rapport à un enrhume
parce qu'en général dans le politique de
la ville dans les quartiers les
démolitions sont bien plus importantes
la majorité des gens iraient reçoit une
famille autrement tout le monde est
parti donc il y aura aussi cette
démolition de ce bâtiment qui va
permettre aussi de tracer une voix à
l'intérieur du quartier et alors tous
ces changements que vous avez évoqués
vont se mettre en place cette année où
ils vont s'étaler sur plusieurs années
vous avez raison plusieurs années
effectivement oui c'est toujours assez
long je dirais qu'il va falloir
huit ans 10 ans pour que tout soit
intégralement terminé bien sûr bien sûr
et alors niveau ur je crois qu'il y a
aussi le centre-ville de plaisir qui va
aussi être réaménagé alors quels sont
les changements à prévoir aussi pour en
2023 alors c'est très important parce
que sont quand même 17 hectares qui se
libèrent en centre-ville c'est pas rien
terrain qui appartient à l'hôpital avec
qui nous travaillons en collaboration et
nous allons mettre en place un parc
habité alors nous avons déjà travaillé
tout le diagnostic et également
aujourd'hui la faisabilité de tout cela
toujours avec les habitants moi je suis
incapable de monter un projet sans que
les habitants soit nos partenaires et je
pense que dans l'année qui vient on va
avoir une préparation forte d'une
construction de médiathèques qui va être
certainement le premier je dirais
équipements de ce quartier qui va
devenir un superbe parc avec le Ruau à
l'intérieur qui va on pourra se promener
mais il y aura aussi des habitations
donc j'espère que l'année prochaine on
pourra présenter les plans de cette
médiathèque qui sera le démarrage de
notre centre bourg c'est un objectif à
plaisir de mener la nature avec
l'urbanisme complètement nous avons déjà
54% d'espaces verts sur plaisir nous ne
sommes pas une ville minérale comme une
ville verte et j'ai comme ambition
d'arriver à 60% puisqu'on est en train
effectivement de créer vous lisiez des
éco-quartiers ce centre bourg qui est un
parité mais également des réaménagements
de toutes de toutes les cours d'écoles
que nous voulons revégétaliser mais
également des des parcs que nous
revalorisons pour arriver à une ville
très verte très très verte un autre
projet qui est en cours qui est déjà en
cours c'est la fusion des polices
municipales des Clayes-sous-Bois avec
plaisir alors pourquoi ce choix c'est
l'union fait la force en quelque sorte
oui vous avez raison c'est cela hier
soir on a fait un conseil municipal
exceptionnel sur les clés et plaisir
concomitamment et on a signé donc cette
convention avec la préfecture et bien on
a besoin effectivement de plus de
policiers municipaux et le fait de se
mettre ensemble dans ces deux communes
qui sont très reliées puisqu'il y a une
porosité nette et évidente par le biais
centre commercial mais pas uniquement et
puis c'est c'était important aussi
d'armer notre police municipale et donc
ce qui fait qu'ensemble je pense qu'on
va être capable dans les années qui
viennent d'avoir 35 policiers municipaux
aujourd'hui nous n'en avons que 20 et on
a vraiment besoin de cela avec les
médiateurs les policiers municipaux et
la police nationale il y a de plus en
plus de communes ivinoise qui fusionnent
avec d'autres communes et qui s'arment
c'est nécessaire aujourd'hui d'avoir une
police municipale armée il y a quelques
années je vous aurais dit non
aujourd'hui on y revient parce que on
entend ces policiers municipaux et bien
le réclamer avoir ce sentiment un peu
d'insécurité et de ne pas pouvoir faire
je dirais un accompagnement vraiment
concret avec la police nationale ça
limit pas du tout au même niveau mais ça
les met je dirais dans une collaboration
beaucoup plus intelligente et beaucoup
plus sécuritaire donc aujourd'hui c'est
presque une obligation on était presque
les derniers à être non armés donc voilà
c'était une décision bilatérale avec le
maire de des Clayes-sous-Bois qui nous
avons une entente parfaite sur ce
montage de ce syndicat de police alors
quand est-ce qu'elle sera effectivement
cette folie nous allons démarrer
vraiment le travail à partir de juillet
puisque nous espérons monter en
puissance au niveau du nombre de
pollution entre maintenant et le mois de
juillet parce que aujourd'hui les
policiers sont surtout sur plaisir et on
peut pas sur développer l'emploi du
temps de policiers Plaisirois pour aller
en plus sur les clés donc nous attendons
d'avoir des policiers supplémentaires
pour pouvoir redistribuer le travail et
puis à terme je dirais avoir quelque
chose qui ne réfléchira que sur un seul
territoire qui sera les deux communes
côté santé les travaux de la future
Maison Médicale devrait commencer en
début d'année alors quels seront les
services apportés au plaisir roi alors
déjà c'était je tiens à lire c'est une
maison médicale qui est entièrement
prise en charge par le département des
Yvelines il faut le dire la ville de
Plaisir
n'y met pas un centime donc c'est c'est
important il y aura la capacité
d'accueillir pas mal de
d'infirmiers et puis de paramédicaux à
l'intérieur il y a une il y a un
potentiel d'à peu près une quinzaine de
possibilités d'accueil alors aujourd'hui
nous avons une cellule qui s'appelle la
ruche qui est à l'intérieur de l'hôpital
dans lesquels il y a déjà deux médecins
et puis différents une infirmière
également qui sont déjà là et qui
attendent cette création et nous en
parallèle on a mis en place un agent sur
la ville qui est dédié complètement à la
recherche médicale enfin des médecins
potentiels qui devraient rentrer dans
cette maison médicale puis vous savez
qu'un plaisir on a aussi développé une
aide de 10000 euros à chaque médecin qui
vient s'installer sur notre territoire
dans le contexte de la désertification
médicale exactement et puis surtout vous
savez je dis toujours il y a quelques
années si des mers c'était occupé de la
santé en nous aurait dit mais de quoi
vous mêlez-vous madame et aujourd'hui on
trouve tout à fait normal que les mers
apportent je dirais quelque chose de
positif et c'est pour ça qu'on a mis en
place aussi une télécabine qui
fonctionne très très bien
un bien on vient pour la bobologie bien
sûr mais on est en direct avec un
médecin donc voilà cette maison médicale
on l'attend avec impatient sur la
présenter au Conseil municipal et dans
le journal ça va être un très très beau
bâtiment et j'espère avec beaucoup de
médecins à l'intérieur oui vous cherchez
encore des médecins et bien sûr oui sur
les trois années on va dire deux ans et
demi de mise en place du bâtiment oui on
va bien sûr on chercher davantage bien
sûr alors la cause des femmes vous
touchent également beaucoup l'année
dernière de bâtiments ont été inaugurés
la maison Calypso et le café des femmes
qui étaient tout dernièrement le 9
décembre la maison Calypso c'est une
maison d'écoute pour les femmes victimes
de violences sexuelles et conjugales il
s'agit de la première dans le
département c'est une fierté oui rien
que d'en parler j'en ai la chair de
poule je suis désolée mais je suis très
très émue partout c'est toutes ces
démarches que nous pouvons faire auprès
des femmes qui ont des vrais difficultés
des difficultés de violence mais
également des difficultés je dirais de
méconnaissance de pas mal de choses par
rapport à leur corps et c'est très
important de pouvoir les accueillir et
quand on a pu en tant que président du
conseil de surveillance de l'hôpital de
plaisir quand on a pu avec et grâce
aussi au département des Yvelines ouvrir
cette maison à dans l'enceinte de
l'hôpital aujourd'hui j'étais vraiment
très très touchée et je sais que on a
déjà des centaines de femmes qui sont
venues et il faut savoir que l'année
prochaine va commencer aussi vont
commencer les travaux dans la maison
définitive Calypso qui est une maison
beaucoup plus grande dans un parc qui
est un plaisir aussi et que le
département va complètement réaménager
pour ces femmes et le la maison va
s'agrandir
ça va être sublime parce qu'il y aura un
accueil médical des coûts psychologiques
il y a de l'art thérapie les femmes
peuvent venir autant qu'elles veulent
vraiment ça vaut la peine d'aller voir
rien que les personnes qui sont là et
qui accueillent ces femmes c'est une
émotion énorme de voir cette empathie
cette ouverture d'esprit alors l'autre
initiative c'est le café des inauguré en
décembre dernier il accueille des femmes
en situation de vulnérabilité sociale et
les accompagne sur le chemin de l'emploi
est-ce que vous savez à peu près le
nombre de femmes qui l'a accompagné
depuis le 9 décembre il y en a une
quinzaine il y a 15 femmes qui
travaillent avec
avec le nôtre la société Lenôtre comme
vous le savez qui était installé à
plaisir et avec L'Oréal également
pourquoi L'Oréal mais pour leur redonner
confiance en elle par rapport à leur
apparence et puis le nôtre parce que le
nôtre est bien leur donne des formations
boulangeries pâtisserie et elles vont
vraiment aller vers l'emploi et ces
femmes sont encadrées par l'association
banlieue santé et quand on a fait quand
on a fait l'inauguration des femmes de
Marseille sont venus
pour démontrer déjà ce qu'elles avaient
fait à Marseille à son nu jusqu'à
plaisir là aussi ça a été un moment une
transmission c'était une transmission et
puis je remercie bien sûr ces deux
entreprises qui accompagnent et qui font
pas du tout de la communication mais
vraiment un travail concret sur le sujet
et puis on a le mamobus qui vient
régulièrement à plaisir aussi pour
justement accompagner les femmes pour
les mammographies donc tout ce qui
tourne autour de la femme j'avoue que
dès qu'il y a une possibilité de faire
quelque chose je suis là on le sait
alors pour revenir sur sur le café des
femmes comment doux est venue cette
initiative alors l'initiative et ben je
suis allée rencontrer le directeur le
président directeur général le nôtre qui
m'avait demandé d'aller le voir parce
qu'il avait un projet et donc c'est lui
qui m'a l'étincelle vient de là et il
m'a évoqué ça il fallait qu'on trouve un
appartement pour la ménager et il
fallait qu'on trouve bien sûr les
encadrants et puis les femmes aussi qui
étaient intéressées et comme nous nous
avons une vraie démarche proactive au
niveau du valibout avec nos médiateurs
et puis je suis très proche des femmes
puisqu'on avait créé aussi des marches
au niveau de du valibout pour voir ce
qui allait ce qui n'allait pas avec nos
gilets roses ce sont les femmes du
valibout qui s'étaient engagé là-dedans
et bien on avait tout ce qu'il fallait
on a trouvé avec le bailleur
l'appartement qui a été refait
intégralement grâce à une architecte
l'appartement est splendide chez Yves
volontiers y habiter c'est vraiment très
très bon ça a été super sublimement fait
il y a une cuisine il y a un petit salon
de travail enfin c'est vraiment très
très joli et puis pardon et ensuite et
bien banlieue santé est arrivée pour
encadrer c'est ouverte tous les jours
c'est pas uniquement ouvert aux femmes
qui font cette formation c'est ouvert
aux femmes qui veulent venir boire un
café discuter et c'est un endroit
vraiment fabuleux vraiment fabuleux je
vous invite à y aller si vous avez le
temps un jour et bien l'invitation est
prise et donc juste avant de terminer
cet entretien Joséphine colmarger on va
passer à l'interview express
[Musique]
alors le principe cinq questions courtes
et 5 réponses courtes nous poserons les
mêmes à tous les mers de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines est-ce que
vous êtes prêtes
allez vous augmenter les impôts locaux
dans votre commune
on n'a pas le droit à dire peut-être
vous avez une le droit de réflexion
actuellement
le budget est au mois de mars
effectivement j'ai des rencontres à
faire avec les plaisirs royales il y a
des choses à dire pour ou contre la
limitation à 30 km/h dans la ville
je suis assez pour tuer pour ou contre
l'obligation du bio dans les cantines
pour mais c'est très cher on en a déjà
pardon
dans l'exercice de vos fonctions
avez-vous déjà eu peur physiquement oui
êtes-vous une mère heureuse oui ça se
voit je crois et bien merci beaucoup
Joséphine c'est la fin de ces questions
courtes réponse courte je le rappelle
vous êtes la mère de plaisir merci
beaucoup alors nous avons été rejoint un
plateau par ATIS Barret le jeudi vous
nous proposer une chronique sur les
animaux et aujourd'hui à tisses on va
allier écologie et animaux puisqu'on
peut recycler les sapins de Noël pour
les animaux effectivement Mathilde donc
déjà quel dommage de voir des sapins qui
jonchent le sol alors qu'on pourrait
donner donc ces sapins à nos amis les
chèvres j'ai ramené pour imager un petit
peu quelques petites branches de sapin
j'aime bien imaginer le pragmatisme donc
alors en fait les les sapins les chèvres
sont très friandes de des
de sapin il y a à l'intérieur des
vitamines elles pourront faire le plein
de oligo-éléments de minéraux puisque
pour l'instant la période est plate il y
a pas assez de verre donc les chèvres
vont pouvoir prendre une petite bouffée
d'oxygène avec ses épines de sapin et
puis en plus de cela bah grâce à vous
les premiers fromages sentiront l'odeur
de résine par contre à proscrire au
niveau des chèvres qui sont en période
de gestation et au niveau donc des
faites vous faites leur plaisir elles
vont manger à Poissy jusqu'à la fin
février est-ce qu'il faut et alors
est-ce qu'il y a d'autres objets que
l'on peut recycler pour les animaux
plutôt que de les jeter à this et oui il
y en a vous avez dit objet j'ai d'autres
objets donc je vais vous présenter donc
on peut facilement donc recycler les
caves à vin après les boîtes à vin après
les fêtes donc nous avons bien bu on a
bien reçu
donc j'ai je prends ma petite boîte à
vin qui m'a été donnée donc j'ai pas eu
besoin de chercher loin par mes amis si
vous pouvez on peut décaler remercie ma
chère Céline Nathalie Georges qui ont
bien vu avec modération bien sûr alors
donc on a ces petites boîtes en bois
donc on va servir pour faire des abris à
Hérisson comme vous le savez où vous
savez peut-être pas les hérissons sont
en voie de disparition ah d'accord non
je ne l'ai pas au courant d'ici 2040 ils
sont très importants donc ils sont
protégés par la loi française ils sont
protégés par l'article L214 du code
tirer un du Code civil de
l'environnement donc j'ai ramené
également de la paille
que je pose que je me permets de poser
allez-y vous avez tout ramener
la vide
donc on va donc j'ai pris des feuilles
mortes ce matin vous allez creuser donc
un petit trou de 20 cm d'accord et donc
on y met d'abord un tapis sur le trou de
feuilles mortes
ensuite ce qu'on va faire c'est qu'on va
mettre notre petite caisse avant
voilà on va la retourner donc on choisit
un endroit qui est calme à l'abri des
enfants pas de footballeur à côté et
puis on y ajoute de la paille que j'ai
récupéré ce matin de la mini ferme de
Poissy je remercie ma chère Irène et mon
chère Alexis
voilà voilà le
hérisson il est très solitaire il va
hiberner et donc il va reproduire il va
se reproduire et nous faire des fans de
hérisson qui nous protègent le hérisson
donc nous protège des prédateurs il
protègent au niveau de la biodiversité
donc ils vont chasser les escargots et
les limaces qui nous saccagent nos plans
aux idées au niveau des jardins nos
plans de salade de tomates et de
haricots
pourront faire leurs propres maisonnette
pour
hérisson est-ce que vous avez
le dernier conseil à this oui alors si
vous souhaitez protéger les oiseaux
comment savoir à nouveau froid les
températures montent descendent à partir
de la semaine prochaine il va faire de
nouveau froid et ils vont peut protéger
donc nos amis les oiseaux en mettant des
pommes poires graines de tournesol ou
alors des boules à graisse sur les
rebords de vos fenêtres merci pour en
tous les cas merci beaucoup à Athis
alors on vous retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle chronique
sur les animaux exactement vous allez
nous parler de quoi alors c'est de la
prévention pour protéger nos animaux
quand ils sont seuls à la maison elle
m'a rendez vous la semaine prochaine
c'est l'heure maintenant de passer à
notre page loisir
[Musique]
depuis octobre dernier Enigma 78 situé à
Maurepas propose en plus de ses escape
game un quiz sur le modèle du célèbre
jeu télévisé question pour un champion
buzzer lumière musique tout y est
Mélanie pocket et Ludivine canard de
journaliste de la rédaction ce sont
affrontés sur plusieurs manches
accompagné par Julien leroyardet on est
aujourd'hui à Enigma 78 au village des
loisirs à Maurepas c'est le premier quiz
game des Yvelines donc comme dans un jeu
télévisé le principe est simple
répondent à quelques questions sur
l'actualité le sport le cinéma alors
j'ai donné un défi à ma collègue Mélanie
prête pour ce défi j'ai bien révisé
après prête je ne sais pas on va voir ça
on y va
[Musique]
on voyage voilà
que la nuit
[Musique]
ça m'a fait des classiques voilà
voilà
Mélanie tu en as pensé quoi de ce jeu
alors c'est vraiment sympa un bon
challengeur j'ai gagné c'est plus
important non c'est vraiment sympa il y
a plein de thèmes donc c'est un
peut-être un petit peu embourbé dans la
musique des années 80 mais moi j'ai
appris plein de choses un petit peu de
cinéma
après c'est selon les goûts et en
fonction du groupe qui joue mais non non
vraiment sympa donc là on a joué à deux
joueurs mais les équipes conseillent de
jouer à trois joueurs minimum on peut
jouer jusqu'à 6 personnes la partie dure
50 minutes environ et c'est 22 euros par
personne énigma 78 est ouvert donc 7
jours sur 7 de 10 heures et la dernière
partie est à 22h
[Musique]
j'irai plus haut que ces montagnes de
douleurs en rouge et noir
et nous avons été rejoint un plateau par
Ludivine canard bonsoir alors vous avez
pu tester comme on le voit dans le
reportage énigma quiz vous en avez pensé
quoi alors comme on peut voir dans le
reportage on s'est beaucoup amusé on a
aussi beaucoup chanté on a choisi
beaucoup de thèmes autour de la musique
mais c'est pas forcément obligatoire il
y avait aussi du sport du cinéma il y
avait aussi de l'histoire je pense qu'il
y en a vraiment pour tous les goûts et
qu'est-ce que vous avez préféré vous les
blind test alors on va manger un peu
plus à l'aise justement sur les musiques
des années 80 sur les séries Netflix et
puis bah le sport beaucoup moins la
Formule 1 aussi je pense que je vais
réviser pour les prochains quiz et puis
bah si vous y retournez vous pouvez vous
identifier avec votre mail et puis vous
tomberez sur d'autres questions ça vous
donne envie de tester ATIS Gabriel le
sujet donne envie là
je pense que je vais tester pour les
blind test aussi merci beaucoup Ludivine
pour toutes ces précisions comme chaque
jeudi Gabriel vous nous avez préparé vos
cinq idées de sortie pour le week-end
alors on commence par quoi et ben on
commence avec du théâtre facile de
vendredi soir le Palais des Congrès de
Versailles accueille Simone Veil les
combats du nez fronté à travers le
témoignage d'une étudiante qui vient de
finir sa thèse sur Simone Veil la pièce
retrace les souvenirs d'une génération
marquée par les combats de celle qui a
dépénalisé l'avortement c'est en 1974 et
en 1979 elle devenait la première
présidente du Parlement européen à
l'affiche Mathilde de cette pièce
cristiana réaline nommé au Molière 2022
meilleure comédienne de théâtre privé
une pièce de théâtre qui revient donc
sur une partie de notre histoire et pour
rester sur les planches vous nous
emmener cette fois au théâtre de 50 ans
en Yvelines oui toujours du théâtre mais
cette fois avec une représentation un
peu différente la compagnie les ombres
portées spécialisées dans le théâtre
d'ombres et la création musicale
présente Natchav alors l'histoire tourne
autour d'un cirque prête à tout pour
être libre au travers d'une histoire
cocasse la pièce interroge sur
l'hypercontrol de notre monde actuel et
la place du nomadisme volontaire la
pièce elle a été saluer comme l'un des
plus beaux spectacles d'ombre de ces
dernières années il y a plusieurs dates
pour en profiter Gabriel oui plusieurs
dates Mathilde alors ça a commencé
mercredi ce soir il y a une
représentation à 19h30 il y a également
une représentation jeudi à 20h30 et
samedi à 18h à noter que c'est un
spectacle familial qui est accessible
des 8 ans et alors dans un autre
registre pour les amateurs ou les fans
de rap vont nous proposer des concerts
dans les Yvelines ce week-end oui on
commence avec une belle tête d'affiche
le rappeur made in se produit à la
Meurice de Trappes samedi soir alors le
à travers le concert il dépeint les
dérives de notre société et ses
contradictions l'artiste manie la langue
de Molière alternant humour et gravité
depuis près de 20 ans on écoute un
extrait de son huitième album intitulé
made in France
il y aura jamais à changer les rôles je
me sens algérien comme ceux qui ne
l'était pas à la base Jacques Vergès
Franz Fanon et la grand-mère teddith
Piaf je suis pas made in saoudien ni de
la MEC ni Doria qui font payer les
vieillard plus de 3 calopèlerinage par
Médine elle m'a dit non si mon père m'a
donné se place c'est pour honorer son
sable pas pour surfer sur l'histoire
[Musique]
made in France
Gabriel vous nous avez trouvé un autre
événement qui rassemble pour la bonne
cause oui dans le cadre de la Journée
internationale de sensibilisation au
cancer de l'enfant alors c'est en
février mais l'association a pris un peu
d'avance c'est l'association Les bagous
à Manon que nous avons déjà reçu dans
cette émission Mathilde qui propose le
concours de chant une voix pour les
bagous alors les bénéfices de cette
soirée seront reversés à l'association
pour la recherche sur le cancer qui on
l'a dit touche aussi malheureusement les
enfants oui vous pourrez retrouver
l'association et la billetterie du
concert sur le site les bagouses à
manon.org on reste avec une sortie
solidaire Gabriel qui mêle qui mène une
bonne cause et sport cette fois-ci oui
le Poissy basket association en
partenariat avec la ville de Poissy vous
invite à participer à l'opération la
peluche du cœur autour de la rencontre
de championnats de France de National de
masculine qui opposera Poissy à Vanves
les spectateurs sont invités à jetés sur
le terrain à la mi-temps leur peluche
celle-ci elles seront ensuite récoltées
par les rest du coeur pour les enfants
accueillis au sein de l'association et
ça se passe au complexe Marcel Cerdan de
Poissy vous vouliez terminer avec une
dernière vidéo avec une dernière info si
vous êtes intéressé par le golf sachez
qu'une grande braderie a lieu dans la
dans le hall du Golfe nationale de
Saint-Quentin en Yvelines alors ça
commence vendredi jusqu'à dimanche c'est
de 9h à 18h vous trouverez différents
produits de golf et de quoi faire de
bonnes affaires merci beaucoup Gabriel
Gontier alors comme d'habitude autour du
plateau qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
avez le plus envie de faire ce week-end
le match de basket ça a l'air très sympa
mon neveu on a préparé les peluches en
plus sera un hérisson avec un cœur
et vous Gabriel et ben le match de
basket aussi du sport et une bonne cause
c'est tout le monde sur le basket
c'est bientôt la fin de cette émission
mais juste avant on va regarder la météo
de demain
matin le ciel le devrait être dégagé du
côté de Houdan et de rambouiller dans le
nord-est du département attention aux
quelques averses le vent lui sera encore
présent sur toutes les Yvelines avec des
rafales jusqu'à 65 km/h au niveau des
températures il fera 9 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie et 8 degrés à Houdan
Versailles et Rambouillet dans
l'après-midi attendez-vous à des averses
entrecoupées d'éclaircies sur l'ensemble
des Yvelines au niveau des températures
comptées 10 à 9 degrés en moyenne et
alors pour ce weekend quel temps
fera-t-il Gabriel et bien une météo en
demi-temps pour ce week-end Mathilde
samedi les températures restent douce la
pluie est omniprésente sur le
département le matin les températures
seront comprises entre 8 degrés jusqu'à
atteindre les 10 degrés à
Mantes-la-Jolie la tendance reste la
même l'après-midi comptez 12° à
Mantes-la-Jolie et Houdan 11 à
Versailles et à Rambouillet dimanche le
soleil fait son retour les températures
sont comprises entre 5 et 7 degrés dans
la matinée l'après-midi des averses sont
à prévoir niveau température comptait 7
degrés à Versailles Mantes-la-Jolie et
dedans les températures atteindront les
9 degrés à Rambouillet alors prévoir
plutôt des activités extérieures pour le
dimanche quand il fera beau merci
beaucoup Gabriel Gontier c'est la fin de
cette émission merci pour votre fidélité
je vous souhaite une belle soirée sur
tv78 prenez soin de vous
[Musique]